- So, you used to have a
show just like this, so;
or sorta like this.
But, did you enjoy it or
did it stress you out?
- I did.
I guess I did enjoy it.
I mean, we were on really late at night
and I guess I was, you know.
If you, if you
As long as your person
you're talking to has answers
to the questions.
It's better.
- Oh, my God.
That's the one thing,
whenever I first started,
I hadn't started yet and
Seth Meyers and Jimmy Fallon.
Everybody kept telling me, like
I was like, "Well, what should I, like?
I've never done that.
I don't know why they're
giving me a show."
I was like, "I don't
know what's happening."
And I was like, "what
should I look out for?"
And they're like,
"It's only hard when you get
someone that just is like,
yes."
I was like, "what?"
I feel like I talk enough for
all humans in the room, so.
I wasn't really nervous about that.
But it is, it is funny though.
Are you really into pop culture?
Like, enough to know it?
Because I have to do a lot of homework.
Did you?
Like, I have to do a lot of
homework with certain things,
'cause I don't know everyone.
You can't possibly know everything, right?
Did you ever do that?
Did you have to do homework or no?
You're like, "I just showed up."
(crowd laughs and applauds)
You don't wanna answer this?
We will edit this out.
- Yes.
- She's gonna edit it out anyway,
'cause I just said I have to do homework.
You're being a mute guest. I
get it, I get it, I get it.
- I had to.
You set it up so brilliantly.
- I set you up, I set you up.
It was nice.
- By the way, what was funny,
is the longer you don't
answer Kelly Clarkson,
the longer the question is.
- I will, I will keep going.
'Cause I was searching.
'Cause I was like, "oh my God,"
I didn't know if you were playing the joke
or if you were like, I
actually (beep) hated it.
I was like, I didn't know
which one you were doing.
- No, no. I just, I was
saying like "how long?"
'Cause I was like,
"Wow, this is like a two minute question."
- Oh.
Welcome to being on a date with me.
I'm like, I will fill the silence.
I was like, I don't like silence.
- You don't like the awkward.
You don't like awkward.
- I don't like awkward.
I'm like, "what are you
thinking about right now?
And why aren't you saying it aloud?"
You're doing it again.
- I like awkward silences, Kelly.
- You like awkward silence?
That says a lot about you.